un choix militaires la suisse opte pour
les avions de combat américains f 35 et
le système de défense antimissile
patriot est l'issue d'une compétition
qui a démarré il ya quatre ans un revers
cuisant pour l'industrie aéronautique
européenne notamment le rafale de
dassault
[Musique]
une enquête est donc mené sur des
soupçons de conflits d'intérêts entre
l'action de garde des sceaux d'eric
dupond-moretti et ses anciennes
fonctions d'avocat pour plus de
précisions retrouve tout de suite luc
allégée en direct du ministère de la
justice on soit revue cas dans le cadre
de cette enquête
une perquisition est menée au ministère
de la justice
oui absolument et l'avocat d'eric dupond
moretti est sorti tout à l'heure pour
nous expliquer où on était sept
perquisitions il nous a informés
notamment que le ministre était présent
qu'il y avait des gendarmes
cette perquisition allait mener par la
cour de justice de la république
suite à plusieurs plaintes déposée par
anticor et par des syndicats de
magistrats
eric dupond moretti est soupçonné
d'avoir utilisé ses fonctions pour
régler des contentieux avec des
magistrats avec lesquels il avait eu à
faire lorsqu'il était avocat la sphère
la plus connue dans laquelle il a eu des
problèmes avec des magistrats a été l
affaire dite des fadettes c'est à dire
que ces conversations téléphoniques
avaient été examinés dans le cadre donc
de la faire paul bismuth la sphère où
nicolas sarkozy était mis en cause où il
a été condamné en première instance à
trois ans de prison dont un ferme
l'avocat d'eric dupond moretti est venu
nous voir et nous a dit que cette
perquisition avait pris du temps parce
que des coffres datant probablement des
années 60 avait été découvert par les
enquêteurs qui voulaient les ouvrir sauf
que personne n'avait la clé évidemment
pour cet avocat ses coffres n'ont rien à
voir avec la sphère qui est reproché à
eric dupond-moretti je vous propose de
l'écouter tout de suite cette
perquisition avait été annoncée mardi
soir dans le canard enchaîné
nous regrettons évidemment cette
violation du secret de l'instruction
comme nous regrettons le déploiement de
force totalement disproportionnée auquel
nous assistons puisque en plus des
magistrats présents il ya une vingtaine
de gendarmes armés qui participent à
cette perquisition
c'est un déploiement de force qui est
d'autant plus incompréhensible que telle
annonce de l'ouverture de l'instruction
le garde des sceaux nous avait demandé
de transmettre à la cjr la totalité des
documents détenus par le ministère de la
justice au sujet des faits dont la cjr
est saisie sont des procédures qui ont
été initiées par son prédécesseur
madame belloubet voilà ce qui a donné
lieu aux plaintes déposées par les
différents syndicats de magistrats dont
je le rappelle avait qualifié la
nomination d'eric dupond-moretti au
ministère de la justice de déclaration
de guerre
le garde des sceaux quant à lui il avait
balayé ces accusations lorsque la sphère
avait été connue lorsque l' enquête
avait été ouverte en janvier je vous
propose d'écouter ce qu'il disait à
l'époque
si l'objectif de tout cela comme s'est
d'ores et déjà exprimées par certains
c'est de m'interdire de travail et cela
en seront pour leurs frais
mon crime est d'avoir exercé mes
fonctions exactement comme on l'aurait
fait tous mes prédécesseurs dans des
circonstances analogues mais derrière
cette sérénité affichée et bien cette
affaire elle tombe quand même mal
pour eric dupond moretti qui il y a
moins de deux semaines a été sévèrement
battue lors des élections régionales
une défaite qui a créé des tensions
notamment au sein de l'exécutif il a eu
une prise de bec qui a été rapporté dans
la presse avec le ministre de
l'intérieur il y aura aussi donc dans le
cadre de cette enquête
nous avons appris que jean castex et
bien avait été interrogé par les
enquêteurs
c'était le 7 juin quant à eric dupond
moretti le canard enchaîné et bien a
révélé qu'ils pourraient être entendus
prochainement et peut-être être mis en
examen dans le cadre de cette affaire
merci le cas légers en direct donc du
ministère de la justice et pour revenir
sur cette affaire dont vous avec alexis
poulain éditorialistes bonsoir alexis
mai
avec mon direct sur rt france on le
disait avec lucas léger c'est un fait
rarissime une perquisition ainsi dans un
ministère
pourquoi maintenant oui la question peut
se poser alors c'est parce que cette
plainte a été déposée il ya quelques
temps et que sans doute l'enquète
avancer il faut savoir s'il y avait
effectivement conflit d'intérêt pesant
entre le garde des sceaux qui était
avocat avant de devenir ministre de la
justice est assez cocasse d'avoir
l'avocat du ministre pendant que le
ministère est perquisitionné par les
magistrats on sent bien qu'il ya une
guerre interne qui fait rage au sein de
l'institution judiciaire entre se garde
des sceaux déjà affaibli par les
régionales et d'autres choses et les
magistrats qui essayent de reprendre la
main finalement sur l'appareil
et pourquoi maintenant et bien sans
doute parce que les régionales sont
passées et qu avant les régionales on y
aurait vu une manoeuvre politique même
si on peut toujours se poser la question
bien sûr de l'aspect politique de cette
perquisition quand on voit les moyens
qui sont déployés ça rappelle ce qu'on
avait vu lors de la perquisition des
locaux de la france insoumise et de
l'appartement de jean luc mélenchon où
il y avait là aussi des policiers en
armes avec leur gilet pare-balles qui
étaient là pour montrer la force
simplement de la justice ou bien
perquisition
lors de
dans les locaux du journal en ligne
mediapart par exemple alex est un signal
de plus peut-être qui montre combien le
ministre est affaibli au sein du
gouvernement ce moment oui on sent les
rides dupond-moretti bien seul même s'il
a son avocat à ses côtés
c'est une suite qui quand même
rend difficile sa position au sein du
gouvernement on se rappelle la campagne
catastrophique dans les hauts de france
où il a été balayé dès le premier tour
on l'a vu faire campagne et d'ailleurs
il a été moquée vu qu'il était avec
rolex des boutons de manchette enfin
montres de luxe et boutons de manchette
à coller des affiches chose qu'il avait
peu l'habitude de faire cette défaite
n'a pas aidé bien entendu et puis il ya
eu ensuite la la passe d'armes entre
gérald darmanin ministre de l'intérieur
eric dupond moretti qui ont très mal
pris une lutte d'égos qui passe très mal
au sein du gouvernement le en même temps
tiré à la limite de l'explosion entre
une personnalité de issus des dlr gérald
darmanin et puis un électron libre
plutôt proche des idées du parti
socialiste qui serait eric
dupond-moretti du mois comme il s'en
revendiquent
et donc on voit bien que le ministre
aujourd'hui avec cette perquisition perd
encore de sa superbe y avoir bien du mal
à défendre sa position au sein du
gouvernement et on peut se demander
d'ailleurs si l'exécutif était au
courant de cette perquisition
si parce que quand même elle touche un
ministre du gouvernement
donc c'est assez étonnant comme
procédure et c'est vraiment assez
explosif à ce moment est évidemment
après les régionales après tout ça est
ce que eric dupond moretti a encore sa
place dans un gouvernement de campagne
puisqu'il révèle mâcon va lancer sa
campagne et souhaite sans doute aller
davantage vers les électeurs de droite
comme il le montre avec sa volonté de
poursuivre les réformes avec aussi
toujours cette ce discours très qui
cherchent à draguer les électeurs de la
droite classique donc clairement dans
les jours qui viennent les semaines qui
viennent peut-être que le remaniement
qui n'aura pas lieu
fra fra fra jours à nouveau ministre de
la justice ou du moins pour moratti va
se faire discrets alors pas si discret
en tout cas aujourd'hui puisque eric
dupond-moretti envoyé valser une députée
qui voulait intervenir des drapeaux
étrangers lors des mariages alors avant
de vous faire réagir et que vous nous
apportez votre analyse vous propose
d'écouter cette petite passe d'armes à
l'assemblée certaines familles
françaises ou non d'origine étrangère
au moment des mariages parfois dans la
salle des mariages
dans l'hôtel de ville sur la place de
l'hôtel de ville brandissent des
drapeaux étrangers ou manifeste par des
danses des des spectacles les traditions
qui sont les leurs monsieur le président
comment vous dire je suis un peu plus un
peu inquiet madame la députée genevard
quand je vous entends dire entre autres
choses ne pas résumer votre propos à
cela mais que nos compatriotes réagir
est mal quand ils le voient des gens
danser au moment de leur mariage des
danses qui sont des danses venues
d'ailleurs
alors je vous rappeler que certains y
lavasse autrichienne la sardane catalan
flamenco espagnol la salsa cubaine et le
smurf français moi madame la députée
quand je vois des gens danser ça me rend
heureux
alors alexis poulain là c'est un
ministre qui botte un peu en touche
parce que voilà il est passé à côté du
sujet clairement il ne répond pas à la
préoccupation de l'est de la butte
député loin peut-être dans gérald
darmanin qui se situe davantage sur la
droite du gouvernement qui peut être
nécessaire emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
oui complètement on voit très bien la
l'adn politique d'eric dupond moretti
lui qui se voulait être barrages ou
rassemblant nationale dans les hauts de
france on a vu l'état du barrage et puis
et puis évidemment de répondre salsa et
autres danses
alors que la député faisait référence
sans doute à des coutumes d'afrique du
nord évidemment c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose mais elles
là encore pourquoi débattent de ce genre
de thématique à l'assemblée c'est vrai
pourquoi le ministre de la justice prend
la parole sur cette question là
clairement au sein de l'exécutif il
était un peu la caution encore de gauche
d'emmanuel mâcon ou du moins
progressiste mais sur ces questions là
notamment question de l'intégration du
respect des musulmans en france et on a
l'impression que tout ça est en train de
s'effriter avec la montée bien sûr des
discours identitaire d'ailleurs emmanuel
macron a parlé d'une société qui sera
sia lisent donc le président lui est
plutôt sur une autre ligne que celle
d'eric dupond-moretti donc c'est assez
effectivement lunaire assez étonnant de
voir ce ministre bien seul finalement
dans un gouvernement qui va de plus en
plus vers la droite que ce soit sur les
sujets économiques mais aussi les sujets
sociaux même si la pma a été votée il ya
quelques jours de cela la suite des
opérations pour les mois qui viennent
c'est les réformes réforme économique
celle des retraites celle de l'assurance
chômage etc
et puis des débats sur les sujets de
société qui seront ceux de la sécurité
bien sûr la place de la justice et bien
sûr les questions de l'immigration et de
la pression migratoire
enfin à moins d'un an de la
présidentielle on assiste élections au
retour des magistrats dans l'arène
politique
oui c'est un peu ce qui on peut voir on
se rappelle tous évidemment de la
campagne de 2017 et de l'arrivée
impromptue de la justice dans cette
campagne avec la sphère fillon alain
faire pénélope fillon son emploi fictif
qui a valu finalement la campagne au
candidat des républicains
et là on sent bien que les magistrats
arrive avec un but de faire tomber le
ministre de la justice cet ancien avocat
qui aurait eu des conflits d'intérêts
dans l' affaire des fadettes bien sûr
qu'ils s'attaquent à eux de l'intérieur
puisqu'il est en poste à la tête du
ministère et peut donc avoir une liberté
de mouvement que non pas
est ce que ça veut dire que derrière ces
magistrats politiques ont d'autres
visées est ce que c'est un coup de
semonce qui annonce d'autres actions
madame champrenault qui était à la tête
du parquet de paris prend sa retraite
elle a été clair dans la lutte contre
nicolas sarkozy et les affaires qu'il y
avait notamment des fadettes et autres
est ce que d'autres magistrats sont en
train de montrer qu'il compte bien peser
dans la campagne présidentielle
en dix ans emmanuel macron attention
nous pourrions aussi accélérer le pas
sur les affaires qui concernent alexis
colère secrétaire général de l'elysée
pour richard ferrand il est hors de
cause puisqu'il ya prescription mais
d'autres comme gérald darmanin par
exemple pourrait aussi voir le dossier a
accéléré il ya beaucoup d'épée de
damoclès de la justice qui pendent au
dessus des ministres ou des proches des
manuels macron et ça c'est peut-être un
message qui est donnée avant le début de
la campagne
merci alexis poulain pour votre analyse
est une société on disait un qui sera
cialis progressivement selon les mots d'
emmanuel macron dans un entretien au
magazine elle publié ce jeudi le chef de
l'état qui se dit inquiet et défend
l'universalité du modèle français
malmené selon lui par la montée des
identités et des particularismes en
cause l'intersexualité là comme celle où
la web culture des concepts provenant de
campus américains alors par cette phrase
que dénonce précisément emmanuel macron
le constat d'une racialisation en cours
est-il pertinent c'est l'objet de notre
face à face
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
bastien ray chez trésorier de génération
s bonsoir bassins riches et merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce soir alexis
villepelet porte-parole de debout la
france à vos côtés bonsoir à vous aussi
merci à tous les deux d'être en direct
je vois donc la société sera réalisée
progressivement nous dit s'alarmer en
tout cas emmanuel macron qui dénonce
donc le cumul des discriminations
lorsqu'on fait partie de plusieurs
minorités
vous partagez bastien ray chez le
constat du président de la république
oui et non c'est pas très bien où il
veut le président de la république à
propos de 7,2 secondes deux secondes du
constat qui est fait aujourd'hui ce
qu'on observe en revanche c'est
effectivement un nombre de polémiques
aujourd'hui sur sur la question des
discriminations en france
et moi je voudrais simplement rappeler
effectivement qu'on est aujourd'hui dans
une situation où l'état ne fait pas
assez dans la lutte contre les
discriminations et où il ya
effectivement des des cumuls de
discrimination qui se font et vous avez
effectivement des cumuls discrimination
sociale est aussi d'origine ethnique et
et la promesse républicaine du coût est
souvent un vain mot dans un certain
nombre de territoires et donc quand on
est d'ailleurs le président qu'à
supprimer l isf
quand on est le président qui a été le
président des violences policières
notamment la crise des gilet jaune
je crois que il est il est assez peu
de correct de s'exprimer de cette façon
sur la question elle lutter contre les
discriminations
bastien ray chez vous vous pensez que
emmanuel macron au contraire a eu raison
de faire ce diagnostic vous le partagez
moi je partage à chivu peuvent pas poser
la question excusez moi avoue même si
vous vous partagez ce constat ce
diagnostic et chef de l'état oui oui je
partage ce diagnostic
mais il le fait au bout de quatre ans il
le fait au bout de quatre ans si vous
voulez quatre ans c'est beaucoup c'est
où seulement bout de quatre ans qu
emmanuel macron s'attaque ou sujets
régaliens
vous savez il ya cette fois sur le
séparatisme et asseyez loi sur sur
l'ordre enfin c'est cet intérêt sur
l'ordre
quand on a mis quatre ans pour
s'intéresser aux sujets régaliens
c'est que ce n'est pas une priorité
monsieur mâcon je lui donne quitus d'une
certaine priorité sur l'économie il a
fait la loi travail
laly sf comme l'a dit mon contradicteur
mais sur le régalien je lui donne aucun
je lui fais pas quitus du tout de s'y
intéresser et ça me fait penser vous
savez aux mauvais élèves qui juste avant
l'examen l'examen étant ici les
présidentielles naturellement à la va
vite et c'est de travailler rapidement
les sujets importants qu'ils n'auraient
pas vu et on le voit bien d'ailleurs que
c'est que c'est bâclé à ceci que ses
ministres et ses les députés en marche
n'ont pas l'air très au courant de cette
nouvelle ligne je pense tout à l'heure
vous en parliez dans votre journal à au
débat entre madame genevard député maire
et monsieur m'aurait dit madame je ne
leur parle de drapeaux dans les mairies
de danse dans les mairies de rodéo et
monsieur moretti dupond-moretti pardon
la renvoie d'un revers de main en se
moquant d'elle sur laon parlant des
danses de du smur je ne sais trop quoi
il faut se re est on si jamais il
voulait s'attaquer à ce sujet important
sérieusement qui vise à féministe
attention je pense aussi à la députée
madame bergé qui avait tenté de
présenter un amendement sur le voile
pour les petites filles qui avaient été
repoussées par la majorité là
majorité de madame berger en marche
voilà un moment il faut être cohérent et
vrai véritablement ça me semble pour des
motifs assez électoraux que brutalement
le président de la république
s'intéresse à ça mais petit personnel je
trouve qu'effectivement il faut
s'intéresser à ce sujet effectivement
cette polémique aujourd'hui qui rejoint
notre thème du débat du jour je voudrais
donc vous faire écouter annie genevard
avant de vous faire réagir va s'arracher
lorsqu'on y marier dans une mairie
française dans un bâtiment public il
faut se plier aux codes chaque fois en
tant que maire que nous avons affaire à
ce genre de situation ça suscite
beaucoup d'émoi dans la population
sahin supporte les gens basterds et cher
cette fois pardonnez moi pour les le
petit mais l'enjeu des noms tout à
l'heure là on est vraiment dans
l'illustration de ce qu'on appelle la
racialisation est ce que c'est de ça que
l'on parle on mélange tout les sujets
selon roman j'ai pas bien compris ce que
voulait dire le président de la
république notamment parce que peut-être
parce qu'il a plusieurs lignes
politiques à l'intérieur de son
gouvernement et que effectivement en
train eric dupond moretti et un gérald
darmanin parfois on sait pas très bien
quelle est la position du président de
la république et en est de même de son
parti en marche
en revanche moi je suis particulièrement
choquée par les propos qui sont tenus
évidemment par marcel députée
j'étais moi-même adjoint au maire dans
un arrondissement parisien
donc j'ai eu à faire un certain nombre
de mariages et de mariage divers
populaire et cette espèce de
stigmatisation qu'on fait est assez est
vraiment pénible et me relève bien du
climat aujourd'hui qui tend à
justement pointé du doigt une partie de
la population française et on voit un
certain nombre de polémiques re surgir
là du coup et qui d'ailleurs installe le
climat politique pour pour cette
présidentielle donc si effectivement la
préoccupation du chef de l'état c'est de
courir après l'extrême droite de courir
après marine le pen et que en mettant au
coeur des débats
finalement des prises de positions qui
sont celles de l'extrême droite
française dans ses diverses expressions
je pense qu'effectivement on court de
graves dangers pour pour cette élection
présidentielle et que lui-même cours de
grave danger par rapport à la question
de sa réélection mais j'espère qu'au
contraire on aura en face la gauche et
l'écologie qui apaisé pourront justement
faire en sorte que la première
république ne soit pas un vain mot et
qu'on cesse de discriminer et de
stigmatiser systématiquement ce que je
dis bien systématiquement les mêmes
personnes c'est-à-dire les personnes de
quartiers populaires issus de
l'immigration
alors gilles platret en tout cas le
maire a l'air de chalon sur saône roanne
et je le var écoutez le le problème
c'est l'afrique du nord moi j'ai marié
des colombiens des ukrainiens je n'ai
jamais eu de problème j'ai des problèmes
avec des débordements liés à certains
mariages de personnes issues du maghreb
donc en novembre 2018 on a réglementé
j'ai pris un arrêté interdisant les
emblèmes étrangers les chants les danses
à l'intérieur de l'hôtel de ville
effectivement j'ai le 4è qu'il nomme
l'afrique du nord en parlant de ces
drapeaux et parce que c'est ce qui a
beaucoup choqué est ce que par exemple
les drapeaux étrangers ont leur place
effectivement lors de mariages sous les
ors de la république française
alexis villepelet est-ce qu'on est en
plein dans ce débat sur le
particularisme
alors pour moi dans un hôtel de ville
d'un mariage les drapeaux quel qu'il
soit c'est qu'ils soient américains
d'afrique du nord d'asie n'ont pas leur
place on dans la dans une dans un hôtel
de ville les seuls pour moi les seuls
drapeaux étrangers qui peuvent voir leur
place et par exemple au monde cérémonie
du 8 mai ou de choses comme ça sinon on
est c'est une question d'autorité de
l'état dans l'état dans la mairie dans
la salle de mariage il ya le drapeau
français il ya le maire il ya le buste
de marianne et c'est tout et c'est une
question d'autorité de l'état
alors attention ne mélangeons pas tout
ne commençons pas mais d'ailleurs
monsieur platret les sons sont sales son
édile a fait pour tous les drapeaux il a
parce qu'il m'a teasé telle ou telle ou
telle ou telle population
il ya la question des drapeaux mais
aussi la question du respect de l'ordre
public
on voit de plus en plus enfin de plus en
plus
heureusement l'écrasante majorité des
mariages se passe bien il faut le dire a
raconté d'un protocole non plus mais on
voit aussi de plus en plus des rodéos
lors de mariages on a vu à lens une
autoroute boucher parce que il y avait
un mariage avec une lamborghini ou les
gens c'est n'importe quoi enfin il faut
respecter l'autorité de l'état dans ce
pays et tout ce qui pourra être fait
pour aller dans le sens du respect de
l'autorité de l'état et est une bonne
chose et les maires si vous voulez les
maires ont autorité pour interrompre les
mariages animer les mariages
enfin pas nulle image mais interrompre
les mariages pardon mais la difficulté
pour eux c'est qu'ils sont un peu seul
parfois ils sentent un peu seuls ils
n'osent pas forcément toujours à
intervenir donc il faut les mettre en
condition pour intervenir je ne sais pas
s'il faut légiférer mais en tout cas il
faut qu'ils sachent que l'appareil de
l'état est derrière eux quand ils ont
des sujets de ce genre de genre de
personnes qui vont faire des rodéos
après un mariage ou qui ont qui veulent
se pointer dans une mairie avec des
drapeaux étrangers
dernière réaction a commenté pour vous
bastien richesse celle de karl olive ans
le maire génération terrain de poitiers
côté emmanuel macron est convaincu de
l'universalisme ce que je partage
il nous faut même aller plus loin dans
notre lutte contre la racialisation à
commencer par le retour d'une
vraie mixité sociale dans nos quartiers
l'universalisme comme moyen de lutter
contre le racialisme parce que ce n'est
pas justement ça le problème va
s'arrêter on veut gommer les identités
aux profits dont deux je ne sais quoi on
appelait ça la mondialisation heureuse
il y a quelques années
le problème c'est que on se gargarise de
mots sont d'une part les maîtriser les
comprendre et d'autre part sans tenir
compte des réalités - encore une fois
l'exemple des mariages montre bien qu'on
à part quelques débordements tout ça
tient du fantasme
voilà et mon contradicteur elles étaient
toutes là l'immense majorité se passe
bien donc encore une fois faire du
fantasme comme on dirait un cadre
ensuite pour le débat politique et c'est
absolument à proscrire et ensuite moi je
parlais tout à l'heure de promesse
républicaine
moi je suis républicain effectivement
mais je crois pas gratuite qu'elle doit
être partout voilà et quand vous avez
des territoires où on ferme les bureaux
de poste où les écoles sont de plus en
plus dégradées les collèges également
que vous n'avez même pas distributeurs
sur nombre de quartiers moi j'ai
travaillé dans des villes où il n'y
avait même pas de distributeur de
billets donc voilà donc quand vous ne
faites pas respecter un minimum
justement cette promesse d'égalité
républicaine et c'est cette question
finalement d'égalité des droits
effectivement l'universalisme c'est un
vain mot et donc moi je voudrais que
on essaie en tout cas de prendre un peu
de distance et un peu de sérieux face à
ces questions qui sont vraiment des
questions des questions graves et qu'on
arrête ce que parce que là vous venez de
nos cités alors peut-être moins le
dernier mais venant d'un maire de droite
qui lutte lui même contre l'implantation
de logements sociaux c'est quand même
assez cocasse mais en tout cas
j'aimerais bien qu'on arrête le concours
lépine justement de des idées racistes
visant à les stigmatisant la population
maghrébine vivant en france se serait ce
serait vraiment une bonne chose pour 7
pour le début de cette élection
présidentielle est en tout cas je le
disais tout à l'heure
génération au sein du pôle écologique on
va effectivement faire en sorte de
ramener le débat sur les vraies
questions de fond c'est à dire les
questions sociales et légales de
l'urgence climatique parce que je pense
que c'est le plus important pour les
mois qui viennent et les années qui
viennent il donne
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
bastien ray chez alexis vinpol est
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
français dans quelques instants rester
avec nous nous parlerons de la turquie
elle s'est officiellement retiré
aujourd'hui d'une convention
internationale contre les violences
faites aux femmes
mais sinon le président r douanes
toujours très décrié une oraison sur le
choix de la défense de la suisse le
conseil fédéral
elle va être annoncé hier que le f-35
américain avait remporté l'appel
d'offres destinés à remplacer la flotte
vieillissante d'avions de chasse
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il concrètement pour vous
depuis le xix est officiel les systèmes
douaniers étaient compliquées par la
mise en oeuvre du rexy le vrai sujet
c'est celui de faire dialoguer les
douaniers français déployés britannique
est ce qui m'inquiète dans le bric side
c'est pas le président c'est la
bureaucratie du brics comment ça va se
passer par exemple pour l'éthique qui
arrive la côte d'azur verra peu ou pas
d'anglais
je suspecte effectivement le
gouvernement britannique d'essayer de
convaincre les britanniques de rester en
grande bretagne pour faciliter la
relance de l'économie britannique par
rapport à la crise sanitaire
le pays n'a pas pris la bonne décision
et nous la respectons et donc une forme
de fatalité
et puis
[Musique]
assiste-t-on à une soviétisation de
l'économie c'est simplement une place de
plus en plus prépondérante de l'état
aujourd'hui avec les prêts garantis par
l'état et c'est fait
l'état se paye les entreprises l'état
pourrait devenir un partenaire un
actionnaire du très humble très grand
nombre d'entreprises françaises
on est un peu dans une logique
d'économie de guerre où l'état a suppléé
on va dire à la défaillance du privé on
est dans quelque chose qui ressemble à
une soviétisation et il est vrai que le
gouvernement n'avait aujourd'hui pas
d'autre moyen que de faire le point
qu'il en coûte
l'état aujourd'hui aide tout et
n'importe quoi et c'est bien le problème
qui va soutenir va va subir ça c'est
nous dans nos impôts
[Musique]
et
20h30 souhaité bienvenue en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez dés
milliers de manifestants ont prévu de
descendre dans les rues en turquie la
turquie qui s'est officiellement retiré
aujourd'hui d'une convention
internationale contre les fioles aux
violences faites aux femmes décision du
président r douanes toujours très décrié
les détails avec médiers ski fis et
bilal abois zone un choix qui apparaît
comme une nouvelle provocation de la
turquie envers ses partenaires européens
depuis ce jeudi le pays ne fait
officiellement plus partie de la
convention d'istanbul signe en 2011 il
s'agit du premier traité international a
fixé des normes juridiquement
contraignante contre les violences
faites aux femmes une décision du
président turc que déplore le secrétaire
général des nations unies présents à
paris ce mercredi pour un forum de l'onu
on voit maintenant une régression poussé
par un certain nombre de dirigeants en
mouvement politique économique et
religieux dans le monde
c'est une bataille idéologique et il
faut gagner cette bataille idéologique
contre les forces conservatrices qui se
développe un peu partout dans le monde
signé par 45 pays et l'union européenne
ce traité est loin de faire l'unanimité
en turquie les conservateurs et le
président turc estime que cette
convention s'appelait valeurs familiales
et normalise l'homosexualité une
conclusion qui avait poussé l'exécutif a
annoncé le retrait de la turquie en mars
dernier depuis les manifestations se
multiplient pour protester contre cette
décision
avec l'annulation de la convention
d'istanbul les femmes en turquie vont
commencer à être exposé à davantage de
violences de harcèlement et de viol
les femmes n'ont pas leur propre droit
par exemple nous ne pouvons même pas
sortir dans la rue
il ya des femmes qui sont harcelées et
violées sur le chemin du marché
nous n'avons pas le courage de sortir et
il n'y a pas de loi pour nous protéger
plusieurs dirigeants dont joe biden ont
fait part de leur mécontentement à
propos du retrait d'ankara une position
de la turquie qui suscite également la
colère des ong spécialisées dans la
protection des droits humains
ce retrait envoie un message dangereux à
ceux qui commettent des violences
mutilent et tuent
il leur dit qu'ils peuvent continuer de
le faire en toute impunité en matière de
droits des femmes
la turquie est revenu dix ans en arrière
face aux critiques le chef d'état turc a
dévoilé ce jeudi un plan d'action pour
lutter contre les violences domestiques
et a tenu à rappeler son engagement
envers les femmes certains groupes
tentent de présenter notre retrait
officiel de la convention d'istanbul
comme un recul
bill gates guichot ballack ya un site
maya surduts tout comme notre combat
contre les violences faites aux femmes
n'a pas commencé avec la convention
d'istanbul
il ne s'arrêtera pas avec notre retrait
piteux jake t un retrait qui intervient
alors que les chiffres sur les violences
sexistes et sexuelles ne montre aucun
signe de ralentissement en 2020 d'après
le groupe de défense des droits des
femmes
300 d'entre elles ont été assassinées
par leur conjoint ou ex conjoint dans le
pays un chiffre qui s'élève déjà à 189
cette année et pour en parler nous
sommes avec bar qui maillent augure
journaliste indépendant auteur du livre
piercing il ya des six danses
théologique et révoltes sociales dans
l'empiré ottoman du 15e siècle aux
éditions les uns s'invente un bon soir
kim ngu remercie d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france donc ce retrait
officiel aujourd'hui de la turquie c'est
quoi c'est une provocation en plein
forum génération égalité oui c'est une
provocation le message à une charge
symbolique importante
il s'agit de contenter et de rassurer la
frange la plus radicale la plus
conservatrice de l'électorat des rohan
pour lui il n'est plus question
d'essayer de convaincre les libéraux
l'opposition socialiste social démocrate
centriste du pays
pour lui il s'agit d' opposant un qu'il
faut isoler qu'il faut montrer du doigt
et il faut voir cette décision de
retrait de la turquie de la convention
d'istanbul comme une volonté non
seulement de défier le monde occidental
les démocraties mais également de défier
la société civile turque l'opposition
turque
la femme turque et permettre en quelque
sorte à ce que l'extrême droite qui le
soutient soit encore plus visible et
soient encore plus offensive sur l'arène
politique turque
vous venez de décrire des motivations
des considérations à l'intérieur de la
turquie nationale donc il ya aussi une
sacrée distance qui est prise avec
l'europe
oui mais croyez moi d'abord c'est c'est
la volonté et d'attaquer l'opposition et
de montrer sa toute puissance
la face à une opposition qui reste
extrêmement importantes notamment dans
les métropoles
là où effectivement la société civile se
mobilise et dénonce les pratiques les
dérives du régime autoritaire et donc en
fait le message est surtout lancé à
l'arrière-pays au la population la plus
conservatrice et là on le voit
clairement revenir à ses fondamentaux
les plus réactionnaires d'abord à ses
seins de nouveau faire appel à
référencer ses
islamistes faire par exemple faire en
sorte que la femme soit reléguée à son
rôle de deux d'individus qui n'est là
que pour procréer et à son rôle de
maternité et deuxièmement c'est aussi
lancé un message vis-à-vis de l'extrême
droite est montré en fait que la femme
finalement c'est une marchandise et que
l'homme a une toute puissance sur la
femme dont on a là une volonté
véritablement de tourner la turquie vers
les 1 16 heures les plus sombres et
faire en sorte que les démocrates turcs
eux se sentent étrangers dans leur
propre pays
effectivement on a du mal à se souvenir
que encore il ya quelques années il ya
15 ans la turquie a frappé aux portes de
l'europe
quand on se les turcs on voit envoyés
sur ces images ces manifestations
l'opinion publique peut-être se
retourner contre eux erdogan sur ce type
de sujet précis tellement alors vous
savez la turquie c'est un pays
particulier parce que on a un film et
féminisme d'état qui est née avec la
proclamation de la république de turquie
c'est quand même un pays qui a été
pionnier dans le respect des droits des
femmes le droit de vote des femmes
existe depuis 1934
donc c'est un pays qui avait une
certaine avance sur la france ou la
belgique où d'autres pays occidentaux
c'est un pays où l'égalité hommes femmes
est plus ou moins garanti par les
gouvernements a été garanti par les
gouvernements successifs où il existe
une société civile extrêmement dynamique
extrêmement puissante et donc on voit
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui même à l'instant
même que des femmes se mobilisent mais
des hommes aussi des hommes féministes
se mobilise également des gens qui
paradoxalement sont plutôt conservateurs
mais craignent pour la vie des femmes
nature qui est devenu un véritable
charnier 1 pour femmes on en compte plus
de 300 morts identifiés pour l'année
dernière cent soixante et onze femmes
assassinées dans des circonstances
troubles cette année on observe la même
tendance
alors la convention
d'istanbul ne protège pas complètement
les femmes des violences
ah mais il s'agit d'un dispositif de
dissuasion et c'est important les
symboles sont très importants
aujourd'hui si on veut défendre les
femmes
il faut défendre la convention
d'istanbul c'est le message que veulent
donner en ce moment même les
manifestantes et les manifestants turcs
pourtant on l'a entendu le président
vert de van sant s'en défend et il a
clairement dit on n'a pas attendu ce
texte là pour notre lutte contre la
violence faite aux femmes et on
n'attendra pas non plus là prêt il dit
juste quand même c'est un combat qu'il
mène où c'est de la commune et des
services cours tous ces discours qui
touchent les femmes sont des violences
faites aux femmes
quand il déclare en 2016 que la fin doit
être relégué à son rôle de procréation
que elle doit enfanter est assurée ce
faire les gars rentrent finalement de la
société de la famille traditionnelle
turque
c'est une violence quand ils homme
harangue les familles y compris celles
de l'opposition
ah qu'il est un traître comme des des
individus ddd femme délurée etc
il fait violence aux femmes donc il
reste dans un registre et on le voit on
voit cette tendance depuis plusieurs
années déjà
ils s'attaquent régulièrement aux femmes
et à leurs droits et donc ce qu'il vient
de décider le retrait de la turquie donc
de la convention d'istanbul est dans la
continuité de cette volonté de renouer
avec le conservatisme le plus virulent
et éloigner la turquie des standards
démocratiques élémentaires
merci beaucoup à barres kim jong sûrs
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france
aux etats unis à présent la tacc du
capitole du 6 janvier dernier reste un
sujet sensible on le sait la volonté de
faire la lumière sur cet assaut
meurtrier demeure toujours aussi forte
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite notre reporter thomas bonnin en
direct de washington
c'est pourquoi thomas à quoi va servir
donc cette commission
mais c'est une commission spéciale qui a
été créée donc par la chambre des
représentants et sa mission joue là site
enquêté rapporter les faits les
circonstances et les causes liées à l'
attaque de terrorisme intérieur du 6
janvier dernier voilà qui donne le ton
de ce à quoi il faut s'attendre pour
cette commission les démocrates veulent
en réalité tout décortiquer et plus
particulièrement les causes de cette
attaque contre le capitole ils vont
évidemment revenir sur le déroulé des
faits de cette journée du 6 janvier mais
ils veulent aussi à s'attarder sur ce
qui a pu pousser certaines personnes à
participer donc à cette attaque contre
le capitole le 6 janvier dernier mais
attaque que nancy pelosi la chef de file
des démocrates à la chambre des
représentants qualifie d' attaque contre
notre démocratie
écoutez la tonalité du côté des élus
démocrates
il est de notre responsabilité
collective d'utiliser l'autorité qui
nous est donnée pour sélectionner un
panel de personnes dévouées à lenquête à
ses causes et à l'attack pas seulement
les assaillants mais aussi les
conspirateurs et les complices
si vous ne pouvez pas protéger la maison
du peuple que dieu vous aide à protéger
celle de votre famille que l'ancien
président souhaite pillés il faut se
souvenir qu'à la fin du mois de mai
dernier les républicains s'étaient
opposés à la formation d'une commission
une commission bipartisane qui avait été
imaginé sur le même modèle que celle qui
avait suivi les attentats du 11
septembre 2001 ce que les républicains
on reproche aux démocrates en réalité
c'est qu'ils aient un billet qu'ils
soient dans une approche trop partisane
pour les enquêtes concernant donc cette
attaque du capitole écoutez là encore la
tonalité de l'autre côté du côté des
républicains cette fois les événements
du 6 janvier ont été tragiques à bien
des égards et exige certainement une
véritable enquête mais des enquêtes
bipartite ont déjà eu lieu au sénat et
les forces de l'ordre continuent
également d'enquêter
nous partageons tous la préoccupation
pour ce qui s'est passé ici à washington
district ce jour là et ça ne doit plus
jamais ça
mais à moins qu'elle est démocrate
n'abandonne leur désir d'un résultat
couru d'avancé
nous ne rendons pas service au peuple
américain aller de l'avant et faire en
sorte que cela ne se reproduise plus
nécessite une solution bi partite pas un
comité partisans truquée dès le départ
cette résolution regorge de politique
partisane et c'est le cas alors il faut
quand même noter que lors du vote pour
la formation de cette commission
spéciale il y a deux élus républicains
qui ont voté pour
d'ailleurs l'une d'entre elles une des
élues républicaines en question va
participer à cette commission elle va
siéger c'est ce qu'a annoncé nancy
pelosi dans le courant de la journée
aujourd'hui ce sont deux élus
républicains qui s'était déjà
relativement éloigné de la ligne du
parti puisqu'il avait déjà exprimé un
certain nombre de critiques contre
donald trump et des sanctions pourraient
être attendus notamment maintenant de la
part des chefs du parti républicain
alors concernant cette commission
concrètement à quoi elle va servir elle
bien elle va déjà pouvoir assigner les
témoins convoqués donc des témoins
également demandé l'accès à un certain
nombre de documents je vous dire qu'il
ya encore un certain nombre de zones
d'ombré sur ce qu'il s'est déroulée donc
le 6 janvier dernier avec notamment
quelles informations possédait les
services de renseignement et la police
du capitole où on a l'impression au
départ on a dit beaucoup que lé la place
du capitole avait été débordé mais il
semblerait que finalement il y avait
quelques indices ici ou là de
d'agissements potentiel de la part d'un
certain nombre d'individus peut-être
alors que la réponse de la police n'a
pas été suffisante c'est justement une
des zones d'ombré que va devoir
éclaircir cette commission spéciale
évidemment cette commission elle est
très politique malgré tout on se
rappelle que joe biden avait parlé de l'
attaque contre le capitole comme de la
pire attaque contre la démocratie
américaine depuis la guerre civile savez
blocs provoqué beaucoup de critiques ici
on se rappelle aussi que cette attaque
contre le capitole avait conduit à une
procédure d' impeachment contre donald
trump une procédure qui n'avait pas
abouti parce que le sénat à majorité
républicaine s'y étaient opposés mais en
tout cas ce qui est important de noter
enfin pour finir c'est qu' il n'y a pas
de deadline n'y a pas d'agenda pour
cette commission spéciale ça veut dire
qu'elle va pouvoir travailler pendant
plusieurs mois
peut-être même jusqu'à l'année prochaine
et vous avez déjà des élus républicains
républicain qui commencent à dire que
peut-être cette commission spéciale va
pouvoir servir aux démocrates dans le
cadre de la campagne des élections de mi
mandat qui auront lieu l'année prochaine
merci mme thomas bonnet en direct de
washington et le gouvernement suisse le
gouvernement suisse lui va acheter 36
avions de combat américains f 35a pour
un montant de plus de 5 milliards de
francs suisses objectif remplacer la
flotte vieillissante de l'armée
helvétique
par ailleurs berne va également
s'équiper de cinq systèmes de défense
antimissile patriot également ont su aux
états unis
ce choix était annoncé au terme d'un
long processus de sélection qui a
commencé en 2018 françois xavier lambert
quatre constructeurs pour un seul
vainqueur après plus de trois ans de
compétition entre le français dassault
boeing airbus et lockheed martin
l'avionneur américain a donc convaincu
le gouvernement suisse berne va acheter
36 avions de combat f-35 à un modèle
déjà en service dans l'armée de l'air
américaine et dans celle de plusieurs
pays européens
une victoire de plus pour washington
toujours leader mondial du marché ultra
concurrentiel de la défense un critère
s'est avéré décisif celui du prix avec
une économie à la clé de presque 2
milliards de francs suisses par rapport
à la concurrence
la décision du conseil fédéral s'est
fondée sur le rapport d'évaluation
l'évaluation des quatre prestataires a
montré un résultat très clair dans la
comparaison des prestations le f 35a a
obtenu la note la plus élevée avec une
nette marge par rapport à ses
concurrents l'avion de combat américain
est pourtant critiquée par certains
spécialistes en raison de défaillances
techniques
des soucis qui ne l'ont pas empêché
d'obtenir les meilleures évaluations
pour ces appareils
l'objectif essentiel sera d'assurer la
surveillance de l'espace aérien suisse
et de garantir la souveraineté du pays
une mission qui semblait de plus en plus
délicate à assurer pour la flotte
actuelle composée en partie d'avions en
service depuis 40 ans pour renforcer son
armée la suisse va également se doter
d'un autre équipement américain le
système antimissiles patriot qui coûtera
plus de trois milliards et demi de
francs suisses sur 30 ans le patriote se
distingue de smpt proposée par le
consortium franco-italien euros sam dans
les quatre principaux critères parfois
de manière significative notamment dans
celui de l'efficacité et il est aussi
plus avantageux en termes de coûts la
décision de commander 36 f 35a et cinq
systèmes patriot doit maintenant être
soumise au parlement suisse en vote qui
devrait être une formalité mais qui sera
contesté par la gauche antimilitariste
cette dernière a déjà prévenu qu'elle
tenterait de monter un référendum pour
contester l'achat de ces avions
même si les chances d'aboutir à une
annulation de la vente semble quasi nul
les avions américains composent déjà la
majorité de la flotte helvétique
et pour en parler longuement avec un
jean luc addor conseiller national de
l'union démocratique du centre membre de
la commission de la politique de
sécurité du conseil national bonsoir
jean luc addor merci d'être avec nous en
direct de berne
alors pourquoi votre pays at-il donc
choisi de commander ce fameux f 35
on le rappelle un la somme est coquette
4,6 milliards rien que 8 milliards
d'euros pour la défense seul patriotes
alors qu'on le sait le rafale ou
l'eurofighter était encore favori pour
remporter la mise
bon déjà on constate que les américains
ont fait carton plein parce qu'on avait
en fait un processus d'acquisition
complet pour deux systèmes donc un
nouvel avion de combat et une défense
sol air
allons porter les américains l'ont
emporté des deux côtés ce qui me frappe
personnellement c'est que le conseil
fédéral présente ce choix comme un choix
purement techniques et financiers alors
que tout le monde sait que s'agissant
particulièrement de systèmes qui sont
faits pour la pour la défense bien lien
à l'évidence une composante politique
que ce soit géopolitique à des
composantes de politique intérieure
aussi dont on peut pas faire quand on
peut pas faire l'économie
quelles sont ses composantes justement
c'est ça qui nous intrigue un peu alors
je pense que avec chacun des pays
constructeurs ont la suisse à des
contentieux multiples d'un ordre ou d'un
autre avec l'ensemble donc c'était
l'occasion peut-être de d'essayer de
régler partiellement c'est ces
contentieux peut et on voit que on a un
contentieux peut-être quelques apparue
plus récemment avec avec l'union
européenne et
chn on s'est personnellement que la
suisse avait l'occasion ont choisi sans
un système européen de de contribuer à
régler ces contentieux
c'est un petit peu une gifle non pas à
l'égard de l'union européenne tant sia
pardonnez moi mais à quel point vous
faites référence précisément vous savez
avec les états unis on a des contentieux
fiscaux bancaire et c'est la même chose
la même chose avec la france avec
l'allemagne on a aussi différents
contentieux avec l'aéroport de zurich
etc
et puis on a une occasion de
collaboration et la question c'est à
partir du moment ce qui ce qui était à
première vue le cas à partir du moment
où on avait affaire à quatre avions qui
tous les quatre ans qui sait le caïd et
sa décharge prévu par les par les
militaires et bien pour moins ce qu'ils
devaient faire la différence
c'était quand même aussi des éléments
politiques de politique d'état de de
géopolitique est la question qui se
posait c'était de savoir avec quel pays
auquel groupe de pays la suisse
c'est en ce moment où pour ces
prochaines années a le plus intérêt à à
collaborer et je pense que c'était une
question d' union européenne à
strictement parler on
c'est une gifle à l'égard de d'état
européens
et ça je pense que c'est c'est une
occasion ratée de collaboration avec des
pays qui sont proches de la suisse et
ont donné un autre signal qui est qui
est celui de la collaboration avec pour
ces systèmes traite
important avec finalement un seul
partenaire quand même beaucoup plus
lointain qui sont les états unis c'est
ce qui retient l'attention est plutôt
choisir un lointain que un proche vous
avez dit c'est un signal il faut dire
que joe biden s'est rendu à genève le 16
juin dernier peut-être que ça a joué en
tout cas la suisse ne risque-t-elle pas
de perdre le train était en dépendant
vous l'avez dit un programme 100%
américain en tout cas nous mettons pour
ce programme n'a donc à deux volets a
encore une fois l'avion et la défense
sol-air la suisse la suisse a choisi de
mettre ses oeufs dans le même panier
je suis pas sûr que c'est comme ça qu'on
va le mieux assurer notre notre
indépendance et est surtout une
collaboration nécessaire avec avec des
pays voisins qui qui nous sont quand
même très proche on a des contentieux
bien sûr mais mais nous sommes très
proches et c'était on avait l'occasion
de contribuer à les régler je pense que
c'est une occasion j'étais alors la
gauche puissant ne l'entend pas de cette
oreille et elle souhaite même organisé
une votation pour faire annuler cet
accord est ce qu elle a des chances
d'aboutir
vous savez on a on a espéré on a voté au
suisse en septembre de l'année dernière
sur le principe de la modernisation de
nos forces aériennes et on a espéré
faire l'économie d'un débat populaire
sur le choix du modèle et on est en
train de s'apercevoir que c'était une
illusion que qu'on ne va pas y couper si
j'ose dire à à ce débat populaire et je
pense que si on considère qu'en
septembre de l'année dernière ça s'est
joué à 8000 voix mais je pense que ce
sera un débat très dangereux et je
parlais de géopolitique à des questions
de politique intérieure c'est celle dans
laquelle vous venez de
de faire allusion je pense que le groupe
pour une suisse sans armée la gauche les
verts tendait un piège au conseil
fédéral
est-ce que je crains c'est que le
conseil fédéral se soit précipité droit
dans le piège qu'on qu'on lui tendait
avec le risque que she does remettre en
cause
finalement cette acquisition nécessaires
pour la sécurité de notre pays
merci beaucoup jean luc addor d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de l' oms qui alerte face
à un risque de nouvelle vague sur le
vieux continent et qui appelle à la
discipline
une mise en garde qui intervient au
moment où le lançons pas sanitaires pour
les voyageurs et puis direction la
tunisie où les autorités ont placé la
capitale tunis ont confinement partiel à
partir d'aujourd'hui interdisant les
rassemblements alors que le nombre de
nouveaux cas et de décès a atteint un
niveau record dans le kent
[Musique]
l'idée c'est que lorsque les cellules de
la rétine ne sont plus capables de
répondre à la lumière puisqu'elles ont
dégénéré de rendre ces cellules
sensibles à la lumière nous sommes
inspirés d'une découverte qui avaient
été faites par des gens qui
travaillaient sur les algues kb
identifié chez les algues des protéines
qui répondent à la lumière et entraîne
la formation d'un courant électrique
comme le font les neurones et comme le
feront normalement les cellules
sensibles à la lumière dans la rétine
pas ce qu'il va dire qu'il voit un peu
c'est il distingue la lumière il
distingue quoi exactement
alors le patient avec la pop 1 par
exemple de reconnaître les passages
protégés dans la rue de détecter des
objets différents objets de petite
taille de grande taille à plusieurs
niveaux en page 2 les comptes et de les
attraper
mais comme c'est un patient qui voyait
plus rien depuis une quinzaine d'années
qui est déjà une source d'espoir c'est
évidemment pas un point définitif du
parcours c'est un une étape franchie
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du long vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ses accusations elle pose quand même la
question du traitement ad décidant par
votre mouvement c'est des accusations
politiques qui n'ont rien à voir avec
les allégations portées devant la
justice espagnole
nous n'avons jamais expulsé les les
organisations des droits de l'homme ni
la presse alors que le maroc les ont
occupés aujourd'hui sont fermés est-ce
que désormais il ya un risque de voir
s'installer un conflit militaire sur la
durée les lignes rouges sont déjà
franchi quand la guerre a commencé après
que le maroc a annexé encore et partie
de notre territoire nous avons accepté
un plan de paix qui consiste à
l'organisation d'un référendum
détermination vous laisser les sahraouis
le choix de choisir le futur de choisir
entre l'indépendance et l'intégration
maroc à savoir que ce n'est pas une
partie de territoire marocain
au carrefour d'une pollution insultes et
d'une nécessité technologique absolue
les terres rares sont au coeur des défis
du 21e siècle c'est un enjeu stratégique
pour tous les prix puisque leur accès
est aujourd'hui principalement chinois
en l'état actuel des capacités minières
connu la part chinoise et réserve au
mondial est de l'ordre de 37 % dans la
cadre de la guerre commerciale avec les
états unis la chine utilise sa position
comme levier de négociations mais il est
clair qu'avec les pénuries et les
tensions que nous allons connaître sur
certaines terreur il faut envisager
d'autres solutions
[Musique]
vous dirigez une des plus vieilles et
sans doute d'une des plus importantes
compagnies de taxis en france l'activité
a repris sdap elmander paris ou pas les
chauffeurs de taxi affiliés à notre
plateforme ont à peu près le même nombre
de courses par jour il avait en 2019
mais par contre dans l'activité rue avec
l'augmentation du télétravail avec la
vie sociale qui reprend tout doucement
et surtout avec l'absence de touristes
étrangers
les chauffeurs sont un peu à la peine
garé ya qu un 5/6 ans vous aviez un
monopole est sûre ce est arrivé là
concurrents les vtc gros gros choc
d'offre
on est passé de on a doublé 20000 à 45
mille véhicules
oui on peut pas à l'infini augmenter le
nombre de véhicules dans paris et
d'ailleurs la loi d'orientation sur une
mobilité réguler même le nombre de
trottinettes et tant mieux parce que
chaque usage pour chaque besoin de
chaque client doit être organisé
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre
pensée deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce jeudi 1er juillet après dix semaines
de recul et 4 qu'ovide ont recommencé
augmenté la semaine dernière en europe
le ms alerte face à un risque de
nouvelle vague sur le continent et appel
à la discipline
une mise en garde qui intervient au
moment où le lançons pas de sanitaires
pour les voyageurs avec un objectif
relancer le tourisme le régulateur
européen qui précise que deux doses de
vaccin semble protéger contre le variant
delta
le coc vit toujours et la situation
sanitaire en tunisie très préoccupante
les autorités ont placé la capitale
tunis en confinement partiel à partir
d'aujourd'hui interdisant les
rassemblements alors que le nombre de
nouveaux cas et de décès atteint un pic
record dans le pays en asie du sud-est
l'île de phuket elle a rouvert aux
touristes
malgré le virus qui s'est dit dans le
pays malgré l'accalmie sur le front du
coc vide en france le télétravail est
toujours encouragée par le gouvernement
le nouveau protocole sanitaire en
entreprise qui sait peut-être dès
aujourd'hui ne change pas la donne
alors quel bilan peut-on tirer de cette
nouvelle façon de travailler qui s'est
imposé avec la pandémie est ce un
progrès au contraire une régression pour
celles et ceux à venir ont dû s'y mettre
éléments de réponse avec l'économiste
jacques sapir tout à l'heure dans son
édito échos
[Musique]
en palestine la cote de popularité du
président mahmoud abbas au plus bas le
dirigeant est accusé par la population
de répression et corruption après quinze
années au pouvoir de nombreux
palestiniens se sont rassemblés dans la
rue pour demander sa démission
[Musique]
le pass sanitaires européens entrent en
vigueur il faudra désormais attester de
sa vaccination d'une guérison du coc
vide ou encore d'un test négatif pour
voyager au sein de lieux sous format
papier ou numérique avec un code qr le
pass pourra être contrôlé par les forces
de l'ordre ou encore les entreprises de
transport parce qu'il semblait faire
l'unanimité mais cliquage tout de même
certaines failles
théo combes premiers départs en vacances
et première utilisation pour le pass
sanitaire européen
les touristes qui veulent désormais
voyager au sein des vingt-sept et de six
autres pays voisins devront désormais se
doter de cet outil
a priori ce dispositif est censé
soumettre aux mêmes règles les visiteurs
se rendant dans les états concernés
problème certains pays dont l'allemagne
commence déjà à introduire certaines
exceptions remettant en cause l'utilité
de ce certificat
le certificat numérique est une grande
réussite d'une part mais d'autre part
lorsque nous constatons que les états
membres par leurs propres décisions fixe
les restrictions qu'il souhaite comme le
cas où l'allemagne décrète la
quarantaine même dans le cas des
citoyens portugais qui ont un déjà été
vaccinées cela montre que le certificat
ne fonctionne pas comme il le devrait
des problèmes internes au 27 mai qui
touche également les touristes
extérieurs à l'union européenne
les personnes vaccinées via la version
indienne du vaccin astrazeneca sont en
effet exclu du certificat vaccinale
l'agencé européenne du médicament qu'un
en effet des différences dans les
conditions de fabrication du sérum qui
pourrait altérer le produit final une
mesure qui touche de nombreux pays
africains ou asiatiques et qui pourrait
créer un système à deux vitesses selon
le programme kovacs toute mesure qui ne
permettrait qu'aux personnes protégées
par un sous-ensemble de vaccins
approuvés par l' oms de bénéficier de la
réouverture des voyages à destination et
en provenance de cette région créerait
de fait un système à deux vitesses
élargissant encore la fracture vaccinale
mondiale et exacerbant les inégalités
que nous avons déjà constaté dans la
distribution des vaccins qu'ovide 19
cela aurait un impact négatif sur la
croissance des économies qui souffre
déjà le plus
dernier écueil les ressortissants
français expatriés qui ont été vaccinés
dans leur pays d'accueil ne peuvent
prétendre au pass and i ter français et
européens
une situation qui inquiète un certain
nombre de parlementaires de l'hexagone
une question écrite sur le sujet a été
soumise au gouvernement sans réponse
pour le moment
avec 5 bientôt obligatoire pour les
soignants selon nos confrères du
parisien en tout cas le gouvernement
préparerait un texte de loi en ce sens
et si un consensus politique se dégage
ils pourraient être soumis au vote dès
juillet ou septembre l'exécutif qui
souhaite relancer le nom de vaccinations
quotidiennes en raison de la propagation
du variant delta et du risque d'une
quatrième vague nous avons fait jusqu'à
maintenant le choix de la conviction
plutôt que de la coercition mais cela
pourrait évoluer
on ne peut accepter aucune prise de
risque pour les résidents des ehpad liés
à des soignants non vaccinés le premier
ministre va réunir prochainement les
présidents des groupes parlementaires
pour les consulter sur ce sujet est
toujours sur le front du coc vide le
candidat-vaccin de curva qu n'atteint
pas le seuil requis de 50 % d'efficacité
selon elle les résultats cliniques
finaux le produit est efficace à
seulement 48% un ton bien plus faible
que les autres vaccins arn messagers
déjà approuvé il revient à présent à
l'agencé européenne des médicaments qui
a déjà engagé une procédure d'examen on
continue du vaccin de donner son feu
vert ou non à sa mise
on place sur le marché la commission
européenne elle a signé avec la biotech
et un contrat portant sur l'achat de 405
millions de doses et pour en parler nous
sommes avec joëlle mélin députée
européenne et rennes bonsoir joëlle
mélin merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france curve ac 1 48 %
d'efficacité c'est pas franchement
brillant si on compare avec les autres
vaccins sur le marché en ce moment est
ce que l'europe doit donner son feu vert
selon vous déjà il semblerait que les
premiers éléments qui nous sont donnés
c'est que les études qui ont été faites
ont été faites en amérique du sud avec
des données assez différente de celle de
l'europe et que les doses en
microgrammes dans le curve axe de 12 mg
par rapport à d'autres vaccins à arn
messagers 30 microgrammes pour biotech
et 100 microgrammes pour modern a donc
il s'agirait simplement de refaire un
réajusta de doses ce qui est certain
c'est que même si c'est peu satisfaisant
dans la situation nous sommes toutes
possibilité de vacciner et de protéger
ne serait-ce qu'à 50% et déjà un
bénéfice quand on voit à quel point
l'europe a fait la difficile sur des
vaccins alternatif aux quatre somme
toute
maintenant simple mais le astrazeneca se
retrouve un petit peu sur la touche qui
réduisent les possibilités de choix et
de des soignants et des propositions aux
patients qui sont maintenant très
éclairée nous nous apercevons que
l'europe a mis sa population en danger
donc même si le curve ac ne protège qu'à
50% il ne faut pas le refuser
ce d'autant plus que nous lui avons
donné au delà du préachat par la
procédure de tous les autres vaccins
nous avons quand même donné pas loin de
70 millions de poti de subventions dès
le mois de mars 2020 et sereine mais là
quand on vous écoute
voilà on se dit oui on ne peut pas se
payer le luxe en substance de refuser
m'enfin regarder les chèques vous l'avez
dit vous-même de l'astra zeneca
même dit johnson and johnson on sait
qu'on a ce fameux plafond de verre de la
vaccination un peu partout pas seulement
en france comment vous allez convaincre
la population d'aller pour eux pour ceux
qui sont anti vaccins d'aller prendre un
risque et en plus que ça soit pas
forcément très efficace c'est ça va être
une gageur je crois qu'il ya eu des
erreurs de communication monstrueuse dès
le départ lorsque l'on a dit il ya
maintenant trois ans il faut que tous
les petits qui vont à l'école à partir
de 3 ans et 11 vaccins en même temps
cette procédure n'a jamais été validé et
n'a jamais été évaluée
quelques parents ont râlé et puis c'est
passé dans le cou aux usages courants
je ne sais pas si on a eu tort aux
raisons il serait d'ailleurs urgent de
faire une évaluation de cette procédure
lorsque tout un chacun de se déplacer
dans des zones où il ya la fièvre jaune
ont fait la vaccination obligatoire ne
pose pas de problème en revanche je
pense que les problèmes qui ont tourné
autour de l'hépatite c b loup que
quelles que soient les deux types
d'hépatites qui son maximum et qui en
laisse et dans la population des
soignants une impression de risques
alors que la littérature ne se retrouve
que très peu de cas avérés de maladies
neurogénératives à fausser les cartes
je pense que beaucoup de français
prennent des décisions sans avoir les
bases scientifiques soit pour infirmer
leur jugement soit pour l'affirmer il
est grand temps que nous revenons à du
sérieux
concernant la france concernant l'europe
le fait d'avoir refusé le spoutnik
d'avoir refusé le sinopharm d'avoir
refusé d'autres vaccins vue de mon côté
véritablement c'est une perte de chance
parce que tout cela a alimenté
l'hypothèse que les vaccins n'étaient
pas si actifs que ça d'un côté voire
même dangereux
hélas à partir de là nous prenons des
risques énormes je vous rappelle qu'on
ne connaît toujours pas l'origine de ce
virus
alors effectivement j'allais y venir
spoutnik 1 c'était le premier vaccin met
sur le marché un vaccin russe efficace
soir et efficace à 91 6% et pourtant
les autorités européennes martèle qu on
en aura pas besoin on se souvient du
discours de thierry breton guy darmet de
toute façon voilà il sera peut-être
homologué ou pas mais enfin d'autres
toute manière on en aura pas besoin
c'est totalement irresponsable je suis
aussi respectueuse du cursus de monsieur
moto et de son action à l'europe et de
sa vision stratégique concernant
l'industrie est particulièrement
l'industrie pharmaceutique mais
véritablement au plan de la
responsabilité médicale et au nom et au
delà d'un concept qu'il va falloir
absolument créer dans notre droit
français qui est celui de la
responsabilité sanitaires les européens
comme les états nations sont graves et
s'il ment irresponsable quant à la perte
de chance qu'ils ont fait courir à leurs
concitoyens
je crois que quand on fera les comptes
quand tout cela soit un petit peu passé
on va s'apercevoir qu'il y a des gros
dysfonctionnements pour des raisons
dogmatiques autant de dogmatisme à
l'égard du vaccin ruche que le
dogmatisme à l'égard du pass sanitaire
qui est dans un sans frontiérisme
totalement là aussi sectaires et
dogmatiques et auquel la la réalité
vient évidemment s'opposer le plafond de
verre il est le plafond de verre ou les
murs de verre si vous voulez de la
réalité clairement les variants déjoue
toutes les possibilités à ce jour
puisque l'europe n'a absolument pas
proposer d'autres alternatives
médicamenteuse à la vaccination
prenons là à tout le moins pour faire le
mieux possible si ce n'est le moins mal
en attendant des alternatives
on verra un petit peu plus tard ce qu'il
en est mais là il faut sortir de cette
situation c'est tout à fait évident en
tout cas le la commission européenne n'a
pas été très dogmatique vis-à-vis du
curve ac puisque on le disait elle a
signé un contrat portant sur l'achat de
405 millions de doses
on a compris votre discours il faut le
prendre enfin
aulas 48 % d'efficacité 405 millions de
doses ancenis qu'on n'a pas parié
nécessairement sur le bon cheval quand
même les négociations était faite d'une
manière totalement irresponsable alors
le curve ac c'est le seul contrat auquel
j'ai eu accès où on ait la possibilité
si on ne lit pas l'anglais couramment
on ait pu avoir un accès en français
mais il exactement comme les quatre
autres contrats complètement opaque et
on s'est lancé dans une commande de
doses dans un pré achat qui a engagé les
fonds européens en laissant croire que à
noël tout le monde serait guéri et six
mois après nous n'y sommes pas bien
entendu mais cela était dépenses des
promesses intenables les lignes de
production était juste capable au jour
où ont été conclus les contrats étaient
juste capable de fournir quelques
millions de doses
il a fallu vraiment l'argent injecté par
l'europe pour lancer les chine de
production et ses chaînes de production
se lance t en avril mai et maintenant
nous avons presque trop de vaccins
puisque nous découvrons que dans
certains cas les doses ne sont pas
utilisés
mais je note et vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure que en même temps qu'on nous
propose le mécanisme kovacs qui est de
dire il faut que la terre entière soit
vacciné ce qui sur le principe est
évident évident en même temps avec le
pass européens nous empêchons cette
possibilité là et j'ai vu que pas plus
tard que hier l'union africaine s'est
vraiment ému de l'ue fait que en même
temps on faisait un kovacs avec des
vaccins pas forcément sûr on comprend
bien que c'est pas si simple que ça dans
la distribution et en même temps ce faux
passeports qui donne des faux espoirs et
qui protègent mal scientifiquement ça ne
tient pas debout
la preuve en est c'est que les états
sont obligés là de manière responsable
joue à l'allemagne qui minent
quarantaine l'allemagne reste a raison
de mettre une quarantaine parce que ce
passeport elle ne protège de rien merci
beaucoup joël ménard député européenne
est reine
et ex médecin m'avait dit un jour je
n'exerce plus m'enfin vous êtes toujours
médecin de médecins également c'est
important de le souligner merci à vous
d'avoir été en direct sur rt france et
le variant delta qui inquiète donc en
europe 1 l'agencé européenne des
médicaments se veut rassurant toutefois
et déclare aujourd'hui que deux doses du
vaccin sans protéger contre cette souche
très contagieuse en provenance d'inde
après dix semaines de recul les 99 ont
recommencé à augmenter la semaine
dernière sur le vieux continent
la branche européenne de l'om est-ce
alerte sur le risque d'une nouvelle
vague et hennebicq decline in home le
recul de 10 semaines du nombre de cas de
kobe de 19 dans les 53 pays de la région
européenne de lure ms a pris forme
la semaine dernière le nombre de cas a
augmenté de 10% en raison de
l'augmentation dé brassage des voyages
et rassemblement et de l'assouplissement
des restrictions sociales adding easing
aux souches de risque lecture et en
tunisie à présent la situation sanitaire
est très préoccupante le nombre de
nouveaux cas de vide et de décès est à
un niveau record dans le pays
pour plus de précisions on retrouve tout
de suite baisse chez be notre
correspondant à tunis bonsoir msm de
nouvelles mesures annoncées par le
gouvernement face à la recrudescence de
4go vide dans le pays
bon sang stéphanie effectivement le
gouvernement par la voix du ministère de
la santé a annoncé de nouvelles
restrictions à partir d'aujourd'hui face
à l'accélération inquiétante de
l'épidémie sur l'ensemble du territoire
une recrudescence des cas de corona
virus alors que les hôpitaux sur
l'ensemble du territoire sont saturés
les dernières animations plutôt
disponible pour information le ministère
de la santé a annoncé juste pour la
journée d'hier 116 décès de nouvelles
restrictions notamment à partir
d'aujourd'hui et ce jusqu'au 14 juillet
principalement sur le grand tunis et sur
les grandes villes de monastir et de
sousse
un couvre-feu à partir de 20 heures et
ce jusqu'à 5 heures du matin alors
qu'ils étaient à 22 heures tous les
événements culturels sont arrêtés
fermeture des mosquées des salles de
sport des à main tous les toutous les
concerts les spectacles étaient
programmés
ce début d'été sont reportées jusqu'à
nouvel ordre les terrasses des
restaurants des cafés étaient pas des
bars doivent fermer à partir de 16
heures interdiction également d'entrer
ou de sortir sur le territoire du grand
tunis
il faut noter que depuis quelques jours
déjà le gouvernement avait annoncé le
confinement de six gouvernorats sur
l'ensemble des pays où les cas de
coronavirus avait accéléré de manière
impressionnante les hôpitaux sont
saturés et si en tunisie au couteau
pitot un manque de moyens techniques de
médicaments d'infrastructures également
et certaines villes comme le cas de béja
où on a eu l'occasion de se rendre ou
encore de siliana le gouvernement et le
gouverneur a n'avait pas d'autre choix
de faire appel à l'armée pour renforcer
les effectifs de police pour faire
respecter le compliment sur l'ensemble
de ces régions là à partir de 20 heures
également le comité scientifique lui de
son côté aller prévu 1 re confinement
total du pays et ce pour six semaines au
vu de la situation sanitaire des plus
inquiétantes et face à la crise
économique et traverse le pays
1re continentaux n'était pas
envisageable tous ces nouvelles
restrictions annoncées à partir
d'aujourd'hui par le gouvernement des
hôpitaux saturés manque de moyens
techniques matériel médical notamment
dans les six gouvernorats ont confiné où
on est au concrètement de la vaccination
mais écoutez c'est pas lui c'est là où
est le problème on fait que la
vaccination a du mal à s'accélérer a du
mal à se mettre en place en tunisie
alors qu'on entendait réduire une
situation inquiétante notamment en terme
d'épidémie faut savoir que 1 8 million
de tunisiens ont déjà été vaccinées sur
l'ensemble et 12 millions que compte le
pays ce qui est insuffisant 13% de la
population a reçu une première dose 5 %
seulement ont reçu 2 12
on a du mal à avoir des doses de vaccin
si son ensemble du territoire le
gouvernement essaye de multiplier ses
partenariats économiques et ses
partenariats scientifiques avaient pays
les pays notamment qui fournissent ces
vaccins cette semaine la tunisie a reçu
500 mille doses par la chine
le vaccin johnson & johnson lui devrait
arriver sur territoire courant du mois
d'août est attendu plus de deux millions
de doses ici en tunisie
mais selon le m s et aux responsables de
l'est mais si en tunisie
vaccination ne sera pas suffisante il
faut absolument que le gouvernement
prenne ses responsabilités renforce des
mesures sur l'ensemble du pays dès
prévention notamment l'obligation du
port du masque de respect bien sûr eu
des gestes barrières l'alimentation des
cas de décès ici et déplorable qui on
peut le constater tous les jours et puis
une population qui hélas par rapport à
tous ces compliments et surtout un
secteur touristique est très inquiet il
faut noter que l'année dernière le
secteur touristique a été pénalisé à
cause de cette épidémie tu coronavirus
beaucoup de touristes ne sont pas venus
en tunisie il pensait pouvoir vous
pouvez les caisses et notamment les
hôtels cette année mais le même cas de
figure qui est en train de se
représenter il faut savoir que 10 % des
actifs de la tunisie vive avec
l'hôtellerie l'hôtellerie qui se prépare
néanmoins avec un renforcement des
normes sanitaires des gestes barrières
avec une obligation la tests pcr
notamment pour entrer sur le territoire
mais la situation inquiète secteur
hôtelier qui essaie de se préparer tant
bien que mal à cette nouvelle vague
qu'on a des russes alors que l'été ne
commence la tunisie merci ben hassen
chébili en direct de tunisie et au
bangladesh à présent premier jour d'un
confinement strict là encore l'armée et
la police patrouille dans les rues
presque vides les habitants sont
confinés chez eux sauf cas d'urgence ou
pour acheter des produits première
nécessité le gouvernement s'inquiète
d'une hausse du nombre de cas de
contamination cause est toujours par le
variant delta dans les hôpitaux et les
services sont débordées notamment dans
les régions frontalières de l'inde où ce
variant a été identifiée pour la
première fois une situation très
difficile pour les habitants
nous avons à peine de l'argent pour
acheter de la nourriture
j'ai déjeuné hier et jusqu'à maintenant
nous sommes affamés
que pouvons nous faire je veux dire aux
autorités de relâcher le confinement et
de nous laisser travailler en respectant
toutes les règles d'hygiène nécessaires
pour que nous puissions vivre en paix
nous sommes pas ici pour imposer quelque
chose nous sommes plutôt là pour motiver
et sensibiliser les gens à ne pas sortir
de chez eux pour des raisons inutile et
aussi il devrait faire très attention à
l'utilisation du masque et suivre le
protocole coded très strictement
considérés comme à risque de
contamination est le tourisme secteur
crucial elle représenterait dans
cinquième de l'économie du royaume
emile et google
alors qu'il roule encore sur le tarmac
cet avion en provenance d'abou dhabi est
accueilli par des cannois où il est le
premier à atterrir sur l'aéroport de
phuket depuis plus d'un an ses passagers
arrivent d'un des 66 pays considérés
comme à faible risque par les autorités
thaïlandaises
seule obligation ils devront séjourner
14 jours sur l'île et subir trois tests
pcr avant de pouvoir se rendre ailleurs
en thaïlande un vrai privilège nous
sommes vraiment heureux je suis heureux
de ramener mes enfants dans leur pays
d'origine pour qu'ils puissent profiter
du beau temps ici à phuket
c'est embêtant de passer des vacances
enfermé dans un hôtel pendant quinze
jours hélas hélas on n'est pas enfermé
donc là c'est quand même c'est le top
voilà je viens pour me détendre après
deux ans sans voyager et j'aime piquette
c'est pourquoi j'ai choisi phuket pour
les touristes c'est donc une quarantaine
en plein air pour profiter des célèbres
plages de l'île pour le royaume c'est
l'espoir de relancer le tourisme
lourdement touché par la pandémie
un secteur qui représente près d'un
cinquième de l'économie du pays
le gouvernement thaïlandais a baptisé ce
modèle de relance le bac à sable de
phuket
le premier ministre a assisté au
lancement de ce programme
il pourrait être reproduit dans d'autres
provinces ça se passe bien c'est
l'espoir du gouvernement et de tout le
pays et ce sera aussi un exemple pour
les autres provinces une réouverture au
tourisme alors que la thaïlande tente de
contenir une troisième vague de couronna
virus la pire qu'elle est connue ou
quête reste relativement épargnée 70%
des habitants ont reçu au moins une dose
de vaccin des restrictions sont toujours
imposés dans la capitale bangkok et sa
périphérie
après phuket l'île de koh samui devrait
ouvrir courant juillet puis le reste du
pays d'ici octobre
et au brésil à présent la pression
s'accentue sur rejaillir ball sonar où
l'opposition accuse le président
brésilien d'être impliqué dans un
scandale lié à l'achat de vaccins une
demande de destitution a même été
déposée hier quant à mme auclair ball
sonar au génocide
c'est le slogan scandé devant la chambre
des députés à brasilia ces manifestants
exigent la destitution du président
brésilien en raison de son comportement
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
c'est tout un symbole ici nous avons une
manifestation qui unit les jeunes les
étudiants les travailleurs qui
s'unissent dans le cadre d'un mouvement
beaucoup plus vaste qui exige la
destitution de ben also know
il a commis 23 crime il est le principal
responsable de la mort de plus d'un demi
million de brésiliens plusieurs partis
de l'opposition brésilienne ont déposé
ce mercredi nouvelle demande de
destitution de gerbe also narrow cette
action s'ajoute aux plus de 120 demande
similaire déposée auparavant nous nous
sommes joints la quasi totalité de ceux
qui ont présenté toutes les autres
demandes de destitution issus de
différents courants politiques de gauche
centre gauche centre droite centre droit
tous ceux qui ont ce même objectif
libérer le pays d'un président qui n'est
pas du tout capable de gouverner
cette nouvelle demande de destitution
intervient après les accusations de
corruption lors de l'achat de vaccins et
mise en fin de semaine dernière contre
le gouvernement brésilien
des accusations et réitérer ce mercredi
par un sénateur lors d'une audition au
sénat
depuis hier nous avons une information
selon laquelle deux milliards de reais
de pots-de-vin ont été distribués par le
ministère de la santé
selon ces accusations the rbl sonar
aurait eu connaissance d'irrégularités
lors de l'achat de vaccins contre locaux
vides 19 si cette transaction n'a pas
abouti gr ball sonar aurait omis de
déclarer à la justice ces actes de
corruption
en déplacement le président brésilien a
réagi à cette nouvelle demande de
destitution
gerben sonar aura sur ses partisans et
martèle qu'il restera au pouvoir ils ne
peuvent pas nous atteindre
ce ne sera pas avec des mensonges ni
avec une commission d enquête
parlementaire formée par 7 voleurs qui
nous ferons partir d'ici cette demande
de destitution a tout de même peu de
chances d'aboutir
le président du sénat est un allié du
chef d'état et bloc jusqu'à présent tout
vote sur de possibles poursuites gr ball
sonar au devrait donc rester en poste
jusqu'aux prochaines élections en 2022
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du télétravail le
gouvernement continue de l'encourager
malgré l'accalmie quel bilan tirer de
cette nouvelle façon de travailler
l'économiste jacques sapir tentera d'y
répondre
et puis direction enfin la palestine
après quinze ans au pouvoir mahmoud
abbas est de plus en plus contesté
[Musique]
le ms a exhorté certains pays d'afrique
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti
qu'ovide périmés il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique lors une
vaccination reste une vaccination savez
la vaccination ce n'est pas elle n'a pas
commencé avec la winter le problème ça
reste quand même l'approvisionnement est
ce que c'est la faute des pays les plus
riches qui accapare justement les
productions de l'accent où est le
mécanisme de la vaccination vous savez
ça a soulevé beaucoup d'enjeux sur la
question de la solidarité si on peut en
faire plus en terme de solidarité de
partage de ces bacs cela c'est quelque
chose d'absolument important on sait que
le nigeria affirme qu'il élabore son
propre vaccin contre le coc u19 pour en
finir avec justement la dépendance
vis-à-vis des laboratoires étrangers
que ce soit le sénégal le nigeria
l'afrique du sud beaucoup de pays en
cette ambition l'avoir amené l'agenda de
la santé publique au top des priorités
c'est quelque chose que nous saluons
énormément au niveau de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
ep
[Musique]
vous allez vous consacrer au festival du
film russe à paris qui est intitulé
quand les russes nous bouleverse et nous
bouleverse toujours vous savez parce
qu'on les comprend pas il nous touche
ils nous font pleurer et on sait pas
pourquoi l'objectif réel profond que
vous avez lancé c'est quoi c'est de
faire de la pédagogie c'est de faire
mieux c'est de recréer des liens que la
politique n'arrive plus à renault alors
c'est à dire que la culture c'est au
dessus de tout ça le cinéma nous dit des
vérités que nous disent personne ni les
politiques ni les ambassadeurs ni les
journalistes et nous y règne c'est la
même culture c'est la même façon de
penser
les mêmes physique je pense qu'il ya une
union qui va se rétablir c'est pas
possible autrement
et de toute façon ils ont besoin de nous
comme nous avons besoin d'eux je suis
optimiste
peut-être pas tout de suite il faut
passer au delà de quelques quelques
obstacles mais je crois que l'avenir est
allemand
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk sommes au bord
de la volga le plus long fleuve d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry allons faire
connaissance vous avez choisi le jour
alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois l'emprunt c'était
en 2011 le monde manque pas un petit peu
non ah oui c'est tous les fromages tous
les soucis sont toutes les les
les croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylé
veille les français ne savent pas je ne
le pensais jamais de ma vie faire la
plonge et autonomie vous pouvez me
souhaiter bon courage
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
oh
21h 21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct
sur arte france si vous nous rejoignez
le télétravail toujours encouragé donc
par le gouvernement malgré l'accalmie
sur le front du coc vide
le nouveau protocole sanitaire en
entreprise qui s'applique dès
aujourd'hui ne change pas la donne
télétravail et pour limiter les
contaminations kobe doit rester la norme
pour les salariés qui le peuvent alors
quel bilan peut-on tirer de cette
nouvelle façon de travailler qui s'est
imposé avec la pandémie est ce un
progrès ou au contraire une régression
pour celles et ceux qui ont dû s'y
mettre c'est notre rubrique l'édito avec
jacques sapir
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques la question donc du
télétravail qui a été au centre des
différents continents que l'on a connu
sans nous au début d'une nouvelle ère où
tout cela n'aura été qu'une grande
illusion et d'allemand bonsoir c'est
fanny alors oui effectivement le
gouvernement aimerait bien que le
télétravail se perpétue d'abord
évidemment pour des raisons sanitaires
et puis aussi parce que ça conforte
d'une certaine manière son image de la
start up nation
après il est clair que les entreprises
l'année dernière avait vu ce
développement du télétravail avec un
certain optimisme
et elle avait même commencé à réduire
assez fortement la superficie des
bureaux qu'elle avait ou qu'elle loue et
et puis est venu le retour du bâton et
est venu le dire elle à la prise en
compte du fait que le bilan du
télétravail apparaît comme beaucoup plus
nuancé voire carrément négatif pour les
salariés mais aussi pour les entreprises
alors tout d'abord jacques combien de
salariés sont ils passés au télétravail
et alors lors du premier confinement
vous savez le confinement de la fin mars
2020 jusqu'au début mais on estimé qu'
avaient en moyenne environ 25% de
l'ensemble des salariés
c'est extrêmement important qui était
passé en travaillant télétravail tota
probablement 30 % si on regarde le
télétravail partiel et même 40%
si on considère les gens qui allaient
qui était au télétravail
un jour par semaine voire qui avait
travaillé quelques jours dans le mois
en télétravail ce chiffre retombe autour
de 10% de l'ensemble des salariés à
l'été 2020 puis avec le 2ème et le 3ème
confinement il remonte mais à 20% sert
pas du tout au niveau auquel il était en
mars mars avril 2020 et aujourd'hui on
est en train d'assister à un espèce de
d'effondrement du télétravail et qu'est
ce qui explique ces chiffres alors il y
as derrière ces chiffres
toute une série de raisons la première
chose qui est importante à comprendre
c'est que la crise sanitaire a entraîné
très souvent une dégradation des
conditions de travail ou en tous les cas
une intensification des conditions de
travail avec ça il y a évidemment la
mise en place du télétravail pour les
travailleurs qui pouvait le faire et là
on se rend compte que cette mise en
place du télétravail
d'une certaine manière accentue cette ce
sentiment si vous voulez d'une
intensification ou d'une dégradation
et puis surtout que si vous voulez ce
télétravail
eh bien il va entraîner une forte montée
des objectifs chiffrés des exigences
émotionnelles et puis de l'intensité de
la durée du travail
beaucoup de gens se plaignent
effectivement du fait que le télétravail
abouti à des horaires complètement
chamboulé ils sont obligés de travailler
le soir ou de travailler très tôt le
matin
donc tout cela constitue je dirais une
espèce de base de fond de la situation
des télétravailleurs
mais jacky y at-il eu des différences
notables entre les télétravailleurs et
autre oui tout à fait tout à fait alors
on voit que 56% des gens qui sont en
télétravail disent que leur situation a
changé et c'est s'est plutôt dégradée
dans la période de la crise sanitaire
contre 44% pour les gens qui ne sont pas
en télétravail est par ailleurs au sein
des télétravailleurs donc là on ne
regarde que les gens qui sont
télétravail et bien ces 33% qui
considère qu' il ya eu une
intensification du travail et 14% qui
considère qu'il ya une dégradation des
situations de travail
par ailleurs il est clair que ceci a
entraîné un accroissement des inégalités
on voit très bien que ce sont les gens
qui hervé les cons les compétences les
plus faibles ou qui d'une certaine
manière et et je dirais le moins
appareiller pour faire du télétravail
qui se plaignent le plus mais il ya
aussi les femmes qui se plaignent le
plus et ça c'est un point important
parce que ça met le doigt sur les
conditions de travail
comprenez bien que télétravail et quand
on a des enfants à la maison quand on
doit garder justement ces enfants à la
maison
et bien c'est quelque chose qui est pas
du tout évident jacques à quoi est ce dû
alors il ya plusieurs il ya plusieurs
phénomènes il ya tout d'abord la
question de la maîtrise des instruments
numériques
le fait que évidemment toute une série
de gens qui ont été obligés de passer au
télétravail avait une maîtrise moyenne
ou ou relativement faire il ya aussi le
fait que les connexions ou disons la
partie technique du système n'était pas
au point
alors que ce soit évidemment la vitesse
de transfert
la nature des ordinateurs dont on
pouvait disposer à la maison qui sont
souvent de moindre qualité que ce que
l'on pouvait avoir au bureau il ya aussi
les conditions générales de travail
il vous savez ce n'est pas simple de
transférer un bureau chez soi alors
c'est la question de la superficie la
question des conditions de logement est
ce que la personne vit seule
ou est ce qu'elle vit en couple est ce
qu'elle vit sans enfant ou est ce
qu'elle vit avec des enfants bon c'est
l'ensemble de ces problèmes qui sont
venus pour constituer je dirais un
espèce de ressenti assez important du
fait que le télétravail entraîne une
dégradation de la situation de travail
oui la question qu'on peut se poser ce
que c'est lié à la durée du télétravail
oui oui on voit très bien que dans les
réponses à lenquête rakow café la dares
et bien il y à une montée de ce genre de
problème avec si vous voulez la durée
l'enquète krakow isole par exemple des
gens qui n'ont jamais été les travailler
des gens qui ont travaillé un ou deux
jours par mois
un jour par semaine dont et on voit que
c'est à partir de 3-4 jours par semaine
que les problèmes se posent en
particulier sur les questions de santé
on voit qui a très bien une espèce de
monter de la perception de douleurs
physiques exemple le mal de dos et si
vous voulez quand on quand on est comme
ça courbet face à un ordinateur ou des
troubles du sommeil qui représente
aujourd'hui quelque chose d'assez
important d'ailleurs les troubles du
sommeil dans la population qui travaille
trois à quatre jours par semaine
c'est le double de la proportion dans la
population qui ne travaillent jamais en
télétravail
cela veut donc dire que le télétravail
il ya eu des conséquences
carrément néfastes pour la santé oui
tout à fait et ça ça on peut le dire
alors il ya évidemment ces questions de
douleurs aux trains de douleurs
physiques ces questions de perturbation
du sommeil et alors ça touche évidemment
les gens qui se plaignent le plus de
l'intensification ou de la dégradation
comme on le voit sur le graphique
mais il ya aussi d'autres phénomènes ne
fait que les gens qui avaient des
compétences moyenne sont les premiers à
se plaindre du fait qu'ils avaient peu
de soutien que ce soit de leur
hiérarchie ou de leurs collègues
et ça c'est aussi visiblement un
ressenti qui a été très fort
la sensation d'isolement dans le
télétravail
en conclusion jacques le télétravail est
il un échec une voie sans issue
alors on peut peut-être pas parler
d'échec ou de voie sans issue comme tel
mais il est clair que le télétravail a
posé énormément de problèmes
je crois qu'il faut distinguer deux
situations
d'abord il ya des gens qui ont de très
fortes compétences qui ont d'une
certaine manière déjà l'habitude de se
servir des instruments numériques aussi
des gens qui sont de très bonnes
situations qui ont des grands
appartements qu'ils peuvent se permettre
de faire garder leurs enfants ou qui
n'ont pas d'enfant par ailleurs alors
ces gens là qui représente grosso modo
10 à 15 % des gens qui sont passés en
télétravail
autrement dit entre 1 et 1 et demi pour
cent entre 3 et 4 et demi pour s'en
excuser moi de l'ensemble des salariés
français
ces gens là ont plutôt apprécié le
télétravail mais pour le reste eh bien
on voit bien qu'il y a eu un sentiment
de dégradation et d'intensification un
sentiment aussi d'isolement de perte de
repères face à l'ensemble du collectif
de travail qui existait auparavant
au point que le retour au bureau qui a
été possible
depuis maintenant quelques semaines et
bien ce retour au bureau il est très
souvent vécue comme un soulagement voire
même comme une libération
par seth et les travailleurs
et voilà qui donne donc à à réfléchir
parfois compte les idées d'ailleurs
préconçues merci et jacky à la semaine
prochaine et on en vient à présent la
colère des palestiniens de cisjordanie
qui ne retourne pas il protesté ce jeudi
contre leur dirigeant mahmoud abbas
qu'ils accusent de répression et de
corruption
des revendications qui divise le peuple
palestinien les détails avec solène god
à ramallah théâtre d'une mobilisation
populaire depuis une semaine les
manifestants réclament la démission de
mahmoud abbas le chef de l'autorité
palestinienne et de son gouvernement
c'est le décès de nizar ben and hate qui
a mis le feu aux poudres
ce militant des droits de l'homme battu
à mort par des membres des forces de
sécurité palestiniennes le 24 juin
dernier le président abbas et le chef
des anciens politiciens et porte
l'entière responsabilité légale de cet
assassinat
nous exigeons qu'il dissolve le
gouvernement palestinien et les services
de sécurité et qu'ils punissent tous
ceux qui sont impliqués dans le
processus de tortures et de meurtres
nous exigeons qu'il écarte le
gouvernement palestinien pour tenir les
services de sécurité responsables de ce
crime pour éliminer la tension il faut
former un leadership national un
mouvement de révolte que l'autorité
palestinienne tente de contenir
face à cette contestation les pro abbas
à l'appel du fatah le parti du dirigeant
ses soutiens étaient rassemblés ce jeudi
à naplouse
[Musique]
nous sommes avec le président abbas et
contre les conspirations et les gens qui
veulent détruire le pays
nous sommes avec le pays nous sommes
contre toute personne qui veut le
détruire
nous sommes avec la vérité la justice
cette grande foule montre que les
citoyens sont avec le président abbas et
l'unité nationale
des soutiens peu nombreux plus de huit
palestiniens sur dix estiment que
l'autorité palestinienne et corrompus
selon un sondage publié mi juin par le
centre de recherche palestiniens sur la
politique et les sondages une partie de
la population reproche à mahmoud abbas
de collaborer avec israël
il y à trois jours des heurts ont éclaté
entre des pro abbas et opposant une
défiance qui ébranle l'autorité
palestinienne quelques semaines à peine
après les affrontements à gaza entre le
hamas et israël les plus meurtriers
depuis 2014 et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis tel aviv avec à
pau la sq ailleurs journaliste pour rt
internationale c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soir
bonsoir pour la merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france on entend d'ici
le plus souvent parler de manifestations
contre israël quand on est dans les
territoires palestiniens lassés contre
un des leurs un dirigeant palestinien
fait c'est assez rare que les
palestiniens expriment leur colère
contre leur gouvernement
écoutez ce n'est pas si rare car ils
protestent ils manifestent contre le
président de l'autorité palestinienne
qui a été élu en 2005 et cela fait donc
16 ans qu'il est au pouvoir de
l'autorité palestinienne et il a 85 ans
il est accusé de plusieurs choses
notamment de corruption
j est également accusé d'avoir eu des
accords avec israël concernant des
questions de sécurité alors que toute
forme de relations entre israël et
l'autorité palestinienne ont été
dissoutes en 2014 sa popularité a encore
décru lorsqu'il annonçait qu'il n'y
aurait pas d'élections cette année il a
annulé ces élections sa population et sa
popularité donc en décroissance
l'autorité palestinienne dont le
président est mahmoud abbas est dirigée
par le parti fatah et ce parti accuse le
hamas parti rival d'avoir orchestré ces
manifestations inhabituelles
il est inhabituel d'avoir des
manifestations dans la bande de gaza
contre le hamas mais c'est mon plus
fréquentes avoir des manifestations en
cisjordanie contre l'autorité
palestinienne contre les partis
dirigeants le fatah cependant n'avons
pas eu de telles manifestations tant de
frustration et de colère tant d'appels
pour à la démission de mahmoud abbas que
nous voyons en ce moment alors lors de
la signature des accords d'oslo ans
c'était en 1993
on se souvient que mahmoud abbas avait
déclaré les accords d'oslo nous
conduirons
un état ou un désastre on peut dire que
c'est plutôt un désastre vu des
palestiniens après quinze ans au pouvoir
il n'a pas pu empêcher l'expansion
israélienne
cela dépend à qui l'on demande
la plupart des personnes qui ont
effectivement c'est un désastre qu'il
n'y a eu aucun progrès entre israël et
la palestine
mais qui est responsable de cela est ce
vraiment à mahmoud abbas
plusieurs personnes auront des avis
divergents
les israéliens ressens de la frustration
envers mahmoud abbas il considère qu'il
n'a pas respecté sa parole il y a
actuellement une rupture totale entre
eux le hamas et la bande de gaza et le
fatah et le reste de la cisjordanie
d'un autre côté le président mahmoud
abbas pourrait accuser israël de la même
chose pourrait dire que les israéliens
ne sont pas fiables et que toutes les
promesses de benyamin nétanyahou ont
disparu sans être respectée donc la
plupart des gens sont d'accord pour dire
qu'il n'y a pas eu de progrès en tout
cas pas de progrès depuis 2014 lors de
l'interruption de la dernière tournée de
négociations le blâme tombe sur les
palestiniens et mahmoud abbas sur israël
en fonction de la personne à laquelle on
demande notamment on peut blâmer
benyamin netanyhou l'ex chef du
gouvernement israélien
clairement pour l'alsh que le hamas est
aujourd'hui plus populaire aux yeux d
et de la grande majorité des
palestiniens que les le fatah on sait
pas le cas ce serait intéressant
d'organiser des élections palestiniennes
car on pourrait voir si le hamas elle
remporte contre sept factions rivales du
fatah l'une des raisons de l'annulation
des élections le mois dernier et
peut-être que l'armée la basse redouter
une victoire du hamas
on pense sur le terrain que si des
élections étaient tenus le hamas
remporterait les élections dans la bande
de gaza et dans d'autres régions où le
fatah était de pouvoir la plupart des
palestiniens dans la bande de gaza
ressent de la frustration envers mahmoud
abbas et ce trait son départ en
cisjordanie il y a encore plusieurs
années
les gens n'étaient pas aussi prêts à
admettre leur soutien du hamas était
difficile de trouver des soutiens du
hamas prêt à témoigner devant une caméra
mais aujourd'hui lorsqu'on se rend en
cisjordanie le soutien pour le hamas est
bien plus explicite
l'autre raison de l'augmentation de la
violence c'est que le 24 juin un
opposant de mahmoud abbas nommé nommé
nizar ben and hate a été tué alors qu'il
avait été arrêté par la police
il est donc noir en détention et ils
n'ont pas donné de raison pour ce décès
on dit qu'ils ont ouvert une enquête
mais on les accuse de meurtre de cet
homme
et c'est donc cette dernière étincelle
qui a provoqué les manifestations en
cisjordanie
certaines personnes accusent également
les policiers de l'autorité
palestinienne de se dresser de
s'habiller en civil et de battre des
manifestants
et les personnes qui marchent contre
l'autorité palestinienne
donc on observe ce genre de troubles
dans en cisjordanie depuis plusieurs
jours cet opposant d'ailleurs qui
dérangeait également y frêle clairement
la présence au pouvoir de mahmoud abbas
arrange les israéliens ce sera ma
dernière question si l'on me demandait
tous les israéliens à agir et non ce
n'est pas une bonne chose
les israéliens disent qu'ils n'ont pas
de partenaire du côté palestinien
14 en 2005 lors de l'élection de mahmoud
abbas la situation les hissera les
israéliens étaient beaucoup plus
optimiste mais depuis les négociations
se sont interrompues et il n'y a plus eu
de progrès pour les israéliens mahmoud
abbas n'est pas un partenaire vers la
paix mais si des élections devaient se
tenir dans les territoires occupés et
que le hamas remporté ces élections il
faut savoir qu israël ne reconnaît pas
hamas le considère comme un mouvement
terroriste et ramasse ne reconnaît pas
israël et appellent à sa destruction
donc il n'y aurait aucune interaction
possible aucune interaction formel entre
israël et le hamas si le hamas a rêvé de
pouvoir afin de répondre à votre
question
si quelqu'un devait si quelqu'un du
hamas devait remplacer mahmoud abbas il
y aurait encore moins de progrès mais il
existe d'autres candidats qui pourraient
remplacer mahmoud abbas qui viennent de
ce même parti du fatah donc si un
candidat plus populaire en palestine a
plus jeunes et qui n'était pas accusé de
corruption remplacer mahmoud abbas alors
les négociations entre la palestine et
israël pourraient redémarrer mais tout
cela dépeint de qui est remplacera
mahmoud abbas qui est qui sera le
dirigeant du côté palestinien
merci beaucoup paul ince d'ailleurs
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir et
dans le reste de l'actualité un cessez
le feu toujours unilatérale en ethiopie
la région du tigré est en proie à des
affrontements violents depuis plusieurs
mois déjà
conséquence certains habitants doivent
prendre la route de l'exode grégoire
auto c'est toujours pas de solution
politique aux tigres et après avoir
repris la capitale régionale mekele les
forces de défense tigréenne compte bien
poursuivre sur leur lancée
le cessez-le-feu unilatéral décrété par
leurs adversaires du gouvernement
central en début de semaine risque donc
de ne pas aboutir à une réelle cessation
des combats
la décision de suspendre les hostilités
a été prise unilatéralement de notre
côté mais bien sûr pour mettre
pleinement en oeuvre un cessez le feu
il faut être deux comme au tango c'est à
la partie adverse de réagir pour
permettre la mise en oeuvre effective du
cessez le feu à ma table conséquences de
ce conflit armé dans cette région
sensible
une situation humanitaire alarmante
nombreux sont les éthiopiens à prendre
la route de l'exode parfois direction le
soudan pour fuir les balles et les
exactions
[Musique]
nous avons des soins de santé ici à
l'hôpital mais il n'y a pas de
médicaments
je ne vous mens pas il y a des médecins
mais il n'y a pas de médicaments
j'ai eu une maladie cardiaque et une
angine mais je n'ai pas trouvé de
médicaments des femmes meurent pendant
leur accouchement
il y à un mois huit femmes sont mortes
avec leurs enfants voulaient souvenez
vous nous avez protéger de la guerre
vous nous avez construit une école et
une aire de jeu pour que nous oublions
ce qui nous est arrivé à à lembras avec
des armes pour que nous oublions cela
vous avez construit des écoles et des
terrains de jeu pour nous vous êtes de
bonnes personnes selon l'onu la famine
toucherait au moins 350 mille personnes
dans la région du tigré
des chiffres contestés par addis abeba
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi prochain point complet sur
l'actualité dans quelques minutes avec
emilie gogh h
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collecte